[музика]
вітаємо Ласкаво просимо до програми
Європа У фокусі з вами я Сана хандані у
вересні понад 100 000 людей втекли з
анклаву нагірного карабаху до Вірменії
тепер етнічні вірмени намагаються
вибудувати собі нове
життя Азербайджан використав військову
силу щоб взяти цей регіон під свій
контроль Більшість тамтешнього
вірменського населення виїхала до
сусідньої Вірменії для багатьох це
швидше за все втеча без
повернення Вікторія геворгян також
знайшла прихисток у Вірменії вона рада
що зараз у безпеці і хоче почати там
нове життя зі своєю сім'єю її новий дім
тепер у невеличкому селі
аралес але пам'ять про те що в неї
забрали дуже сильна Її дім знаходиться в
нагірному карабаху вона впевнена що вже
ніколи не зможе туди
повернутися такі ж яблука висять і у її
саду вдома у нагірному
карабаху але вікторія геворгян більше не
може їх збирати після втечі від
азербайджанських ракет Вона живе зі
своєю невісткою анаїт та онуком арзвіком
тут в аралезі в
ірменія вона винаймає житло у цієї
жінки коли Вікторія згадує про все що
вона втратила вона пече коржики з
кропивою Та коріандром це поширена
страва у нагірному карабаху це пробуджує
її спогади і дає трохи
розради вони дуже гострі там багато
перцю Вікторії довелося покинути свій
дім без жодних
попереджень нам довелося покинути все
залишився тільки одяг який у нас був
більше
нічого ми в шістьох поїхали на маленький
машині ми взяли лише дві ковдри щоб
вкриватись
уночі через раптову атаку Азербайджану
на Нагірний Карабах людям довелося
масово
тікати усього за кілька днів понад 100
000 етнічних вірмен втекли з анклаву до
Вірменії через лачинський коридор у
горах вони боялися що їх
переслідуватимуть через їхню багато
боротьбу за незалежність після війни між
цими сусідніми країнами роки тому регіон
опинився під контролем Азербайджану
вірмени Тут були змушені визнати
суверенітет Азербайджану над
регіоном і тепер десятки тисяч людей з
нагірного карабаху які сім'я геворгян
мають починати все з нуля у
[музика]
Вірменії вони в п'ятьох ділятьсяцей
внутрішній дворик і дві крихітні кімнати
батько маленького арзвіка знайшов роботу
таксистом його старша сестра не хоче щоб
її
знімали Хіба це можна описати словами
ні кожного дня малий запитує коли ми
повернемося
щодня вранці і
ввечері Вірменія прийняла біженців у
багатьох із них не залишило Нічого І
вони потребують державної підтримки
Європейський союз та міжнародні
гуманітарні організації надсилають
допомогу але ця бідна Кавказька країна
перевантажена прибуття понад 100 000
людей з негірного карабаху створює
величезне навантаження на вірменську
економіку особливо це стосується банків
адже у більшості біженців є
борги у нагірному карабасі були тільки
вірменські банки і зараз вони
заборгували близ півмільярда
доларів як і десятки сімей біженців
геворгяни втекли з нагірного карабаху і
приїхали в село арелес Майже без нічого
це приблизно 45 кмт від столиці Вірменії
Єревана Багато з них психологічно
травмовані через вимушену втечу та війну
між вірменією та азербайджаном роки
тому на цьому кладовищі у Єревані
поховано багато солдатів близько 4 000
вірме загинули тоді майже кожна сім'я
оплакувала загиблого або скаліченого
знайомого друга чи члена сім'ї у тому
числі і Вікторія геворгян її онука
загинула від ракетного
удару діти чекали на таксі щоб доїхати
до підземного
сховища була 7:10
ранку прямо на нас полетіла
ракета дві мої невістки отримали
поранення онукові влучила в голову руку
і ногу у нього була сильна
кровотеча ця війна стала серйозним
переломним моментом для вірмен тому що
їхній ключовий стратегічний союзник
Росія надавала все менше
підтримки у нагірному карабаху ще може й
залишалися російські миротворці які
захищали вірменське населення але вздовж
азербайджану-вірменського кордону часто
відбувалися обстріли і навіть зараз коли
Азербайджан напав на Нагірний Карабах
Москва не втрутилася щоб
допомогти до нас після цього всього
прийшло прозріння Ми зрозуміли що ми
одні що в нас немає
союзників це трагедія і нам боляче
говорити про те що Росія один і
винуватців цієї трагедії як і багато
біженців з нагірного карабаху сім'я
геворгян відчуває себе у небезпеці
пам'ятаючи про долю яка спіткала
багатьох їхніх співвітчизників понад
століття тому коли геноцид забрав життя
сотень тисяч
вірмен У мене є не план а мрія поїхати в
арцах провідати могилу моєї
доньки але я не хочу щоб діти Зараз жили
там не хочу втрачати
їх тому що Карабах для мене воєнна зона
і він завжди таким
буде ми нікому не віримо ні владі
нікому
тільки
собі що буде з нами я не знаю навіть не
здогадуюсь
даже Вікторія геворгн її сім'я та багато
інших біженців і не сподіваються що
зможуть повернутися до нагірного
карабаху наразі все що у них залишилося
це їхні
спогади Сербія має особливо тісні
взаємини з Китаєм особливо якщо говорити
про
економіку поки Сербія шукає Інвестиції
на далекому сході китайці прагнуть
розширити свій вплив в
Європі саме тому кілька років тому вони
придбали металургійний завод смедерове
на півдні белграда відтоді все більше
людей У сусідньому селі радінац
скаржаться на жахливе забруднення
повітря від цього заводу драганаміліч
живе там уже чотири десятиліття вона
каже що ніколи не було так погано І вона
боїться що так буде ій надалі адже цей
металургійний завод забезпечує тисячі
робочих місць у частині Сербії Яка й так
дуже
бідна що у нас в
легенях якщо це на ліхтарному стовпі то
що в наших легенях і всередині наших тіл
ніхто не знає
радінац невелике село неподалік белграда
тут помирає багато
людей їхні фотографії на ліхтарних
стовпах вкриті червоним
пилом Драгана міліч розповідає мені що
залюбки переїхала б зі свого села але
ніхто не хоче купувати її
будинок він теж вкритий густим червоним
пилом який викидає металургійний
комбінат що знаходиться навпроти її
помешкання погляньте туди бачите скільки
диму
там де 10 років тому мешкало понад 5 000
людей тепер дедалі частіше зустрічаються
порожні
будинки молодь зокрема покидає село В
пошуках більш високооплачуваної
роботи цей металургійний завод одне із
найстаріших промислових підприємств яке
часто називають гордістю
Сербії він забезпечує тисячі робочих
місць у цьому регіоні і мав різних
власників від сербської держави він
переходив у власність американської
компанії А у 2012 році знову став
сербським
заводом із 2016 року завод належить
китайській державі
Що ж тут змінилося з приходом
Китаю тут важко говорити з місцевими
жителями на камеру люди кажуть що
бояться
ця пара теж не хоче щоб їх впізнали їхні
діти працюють на сербський уряд за
іронією долі у сфері охорони здоров'я
кажуть
вони але вони хочуть щоб ми зафільмували
цю фотографію вони зняли гігантську
брудну хмару над
заводо іноді Ми чуємо вибухи А вони
кажуть що беруші від цього шуму це все
що вони можуть
вдіяти вони просто чекають доки люди
помруть і ще до того як сюди прийшли
китайці на адресу цього металургійного
підприємства лунала
критика за даними обласної лікарні в
смедерове за останні десятиліття рівень
захворюваності на ракту збільшився у
чотири
рази екологічні активісти такі як Нікола
рстіч хочуть щоб завод бу введено до
ладу і вимагають встановлення фільтрів
проти забруднення він очолює наглядову
Раду у смедерове Нікола ходить від хати
до хати щоб з'ясувати як це впливає на
людей у вас є якісь проблеми пов'язані з
цим пилом звісно є і якість води не дуже
хороша у кожного Тут є що сказати
стосовно заводу Нікола хоче вислухати і
зібрати якомога більше доказів- каже він
то Са то я мене знам
не у мене було дві великі пухлини за два
роки у вас є якісь Надії що все стане
краще ситуація дуже
тривожна Моя дружина хоче щоб ми
переїхали звідси Не тільки через неї але
й заради майбутнього наших
дітей у нас троє дітей і ситуація не
покращується
і ми не сподіваємося що це зміниться
найближчим
часом активісти включаючи ніколу кажуть
що зміни гальмуються частково через те
що Сербська держава нібито не хоче
забезпечувати дотримання екологічних
стандартів Люди які працюють на цьому
металургійному заводі занепокоєні тим що
можуть втратити
роботу це парадокс тому що з одного боку
у вас єди ди для яких завод - це джерело
засобів до
існування також є емоційна складова тому
що не одне покоління працювало на цьому
заводі але з іншого боку цей самий завод
їх вбиває отруює кожного
[музика]
дня інші екологічні організації
поділяють таку оцінку але для багатьох
Хто живе тут металургійний заводу
смедерове здається єдиним порятунком ви
без того бідній частині
Сербії
мати роботу це важливіше ніж
довкілля мене особисто більше турбує щоб
люди не втратили роботу і щоб це
забруднення не впливало на
нас китайський та сербській прапори
видно на під'їзді до цього
металургійного заводу яким керує
китайський інвестор
hbis Ми попросили дозволу на зйомку
всередині але наше прохання залишилось
без
відповіді ми хочемо спробувати ще
раз камерам тут не
раді нам все ж вдається
познімати далі ми мали дивну розмову із
представником зі зв'язків з
громадськістю на тлі плакату що пропагує
політику захисту
довкілля тобто я маю поїхати до Китаю
щоб попросити про інтерв'ю щоб
поговорити з кимось тут у Сербії і це
нормальна процедура ми отримуємо ще одну
електронну адресу і робимо ще один запит
Але знову ніякої
реакції наша наступна зупинка Белград
столиця Ми хочемо з'ясувати чи
проводяться перевірки з боку сербської
держави наші письмові запити до
мінохорони здоров'я та Міністерство
охорони довкілля залишаються без
відповіді наші телефонні звернення
безрезультатні
Натомість ми зустрічаємося із міленком
йовановичем у белградському лісі у 2021
році Він збирав зразки пилу з цього
металургійного заводу для національної
екологічної асоціації на урядової
організації яку він заснував щоб виявити
екологічні проблеми та оприлюднити їх
які ж його висновки
миж як кадмій хром свинець ртуть нікель
не повинно бути в повітрі це токсичні
матеріали важкі метали які викликають
рак їх там не повинно
бути за його словами ті хто ставить
прибуток вище за здоров'я людей мають
бути покарані він звертається до уряду
Сербії держава повинна діяти завод
знаходиться під контролем
держави Нам потрібні прозорість д
розкажіть їм в чому проблема Чому і де
трапляються інциденти і як себе
захистити потрібні адекватні фільтри і
завод повинен продовжувати
працювати повертаємось до радінаца Драга
на міліч покладає всі свої надії на
екологічних активістів які пообіцяли їй
що вони подадуть справу до Європейського
суду зправ людини вона каже що всі тут
знають що не так але люди які виступають
проти переві не хочуть розуміти ніхто не
хоче закривати завод а лише хочуть
зупинити токсичні відходи які отруюють
село боротьба забирає у неї багато сил
вона каже що це
висжує її мрія
проста Чесно кажучи я б хотіла вийти на
пенсію
і провести решту життя з онуками це моє
єдине
бажання її онуки приїжджають
рідко тут небезпечно будчого торкатися
чи гратися на вулиці каже Драгана її
життя дедалі більше обмежується чотирма
стінами її
оселі її життя здебільшого проходить
поза домом Юлі з Туреччини займається
танцями
даючи нічні вистави у Стамбулі
танцівниця представляє багатовікову
традицію яка є невід'ємною частиною
турецької культури але Туреччина зараз
перебуває в економічній кризі інфляція
перевищує 60% а вити кудись ввечері стає
дедалі дорожче Що заважає людям
насолоджуватися нічним
життям крім того народ Туреччини з
кожним роком стає усбільш консервативним
під владою ісламського
уряду це ускладнює дляю моливоі
заробляти на життя
танцями танець живота основне джерело
доходу гюль щовечора танцівниця виступає
у барах і ресторанах
Стамбула ця форма танцю розважає людей
на босфорі вже багато
століть але гюль помітила що
відвідувачам стає дедалі важче
розслабитися і насолодитися
шоу
сьогодні вони серйозно замислюються над
тим скільки саме страв яких напоїв На
яку суму вони замовлять раніше все було
інакше на вихідних люди дозволяли собі
розслабитись але ці дні минули
традиційно танцівницям платять виключно
гості вкладаючи гроші у їхнє
вбрання цього вечора більшість дає
купюри постолір що еквівалентно
приблизно 3 євро кожна Юль яка хоче щоб
ми використовували її сценічне ім'я знає
що багато хто не може дозволити собі
дати більше але є й інші
проблеми вони заборонили танець живота
на телебаченні усе стає дедалі
консервативнішим орендодавці більше не
хочуть здавати мені житло тому що я
заробляю гроші танцем
живота вони кажуть Чому я повинен
здавати житло такій
людині після нічних танців і виступів у
може трохи відпочити коли приходить
додому з колегою вона згадує часи коли
Туреччина була ліберальнішою і справи
йшли краще вона каже що колись танець
живота був поважною
професією Коли я була маленькою вся
сім'я проводила новорічну ніч перед
телевізором зачаровано дивлячись на
[музика]
танцівниць зрештою таке виховання має
вплив на
всіх не тільки на нас танцівнить але й
на всіх жінок у
Туреччині з кожним роком країна стає все
більш консервативною і в той же час
економіка падає турецька Ліра продовжує
втрачати все більше своєї вартості
відносно долара і євро А з інфляцією яка
за офіційними даними становить 62% вже
мало хто може дозволити собі виходити
кудись
тому у пабах барах і розважальних
закладах порожніх столиків стає дедалі
більше а зазвичай ми спочатку заглядаємо
в кілька місць і обираємо
найдешевше раніше я вибирався раз на
тиждень тепер раз на
місяць постійне зростання цін на
алкоголь особливо сильно вдарило по
сектору
розваг зростання цін призвело до того що
дедалі більше людей виготовляють власний
алкоголь вдома
Юль починає готуватися до вечірнього шоу
вона не знає скільки ще зможе заробляти
на життя танцями вона отримує все менше
чайових а витрати тільки
збільшуються мої костюми дорожчають
щомісяця Кравець каже мені долар виріс
матеріали блискітки коштують
дорожче Якби я могла ла вго наперед і
просто
запаслася але я не
можу тож єдине що залишається гюль
чекати кращих часів у сфері розваг
більшого визнання і перш за все кращих
[музика]
доходів
сезони змінюються і зима приносить
коротші та холодніші дні особливо якщо
ви живете на півночі Європи лулео
розташоване на узбережжі Північної
Швеції знаходиться близько до полярного
кола зими тут дуже темні холодні і
самотні щоб боротися з цією самотністю а
саковскі та євабрт чернквіст придумали
особливу
компанію вона покликана підняти настрій
не лише жителям міста а і його
гостям
коли йонас Бітнер виходить на вулицю то
щоб не замерзнути одягає два пальта
20тирічний хлопець родом із Мюнхена
приїхав до лулео три місяці тому він
хотів побачити як живеться на півночі
Швеції не назавжди тут занадто темно для
цього але я подумав що на півроку це
буде цікаво він їде на лекцію сьогодні
мі12°
зацель Йона швидко зрозумів що йому
доведеться звикати до іншої кількості
сонячного
[оплески]
світла тут темніє вже о 3тй годині дуже
відрізняється від Німеччини Тут набагато
менше сонячного світла переважно хмарно
ніколи не буває дуже ясно О 4ртій годині
практично можна лягати спати у лекційній
аудиторії достатньо світла щоб студенти
залишалися уважними але надворі все ще
холодно і похмуро індустріальне місто
лулео не жається взірцем краси тут
знаходиться великий металургійний завод
із Порту незабаром вийдуть криголами щоб
очистити Балтійське море від
льоду люди часто проходять один повз
одного не вітаючись згідно з нещодавнім
опитуванням кожна четверта людина у
Швеції почувається самотньою тому було
запущено кампанію яка заохочує Людей
просто казати один одному Хей або
[музика]
Привіт цю ідею придумали аса коскі та
євабрід чернквіст і не
дарма існують Дослідження які показують
що привітання позитивно впливає на
самопочуття і здоров'я
людей ми відчували що маємо щось
[оплески]
зробити вони подають хороший приклад у
лулео самотність відчувають не лише
старші люди коскі каже що люди віком від
16 до 29 років також Часто почуваються
самотніми вона прийшла до цієї старшої
школи щоб поговорити про це із учнями Ви
вітаєтеся зі своїми однокласниками в
коридорі якщо хтось проходить повз Я
піднімаю очі але багато хто просто йде
далі з непорушним виразом
обличчя я не думаю що цієї компанії буде
достатньо щоб усе
змінити звички людей важко
змінити іноді звички потрібно ламати як
лід на балтиці лід не лякає понтуса
вікструма який заснував асоціацію
зимового купання у лулео і навіть молодь
теж не боїться
холоду разом веселіше
соціальніше так би
мовити асоціація вже налічує 500 членів
більшість із них приходять на вихідні
але в сауні майже завжди є вільні місця
немає нічого кращого Для боротьби з
самотністю ніж разом попітніти і
зануритись у крижану воду
це хороший спосіб познайомитися з людьми
особливо для тих хто Самотній не з
власної волі
принаймні тут вони можуть відчути себе
краще на деякий
час попереду все ще трохи темряви адже
дні ставатимуть коротшими аж до зимового
сонцестояння
йонас Бітнер знайшов спосіб аби темрява
впливала на нього
менше він часто ходить на прогулянки до
лісу із другом на півночі Швеції є
багато способів боротися із самот
відкрите вогнище чи дружнє Хей можуть
допомогти А на сьогодні це все дякуємо
за перегляди до зустрічі за тиждень у
наступному випуску програми Європа У
[музика]
фокусі
than